Is it necessary to do anything else other than the homeopathic you recommend to mitigate the effects of CT PET scans?
Does the rife have any helpful things to do?
And if so, how often do you do this?
And do you do at pre-imposed scans?
So, the homeopaths, you can start taking it before you scan, you can start taking it any time.
So, if you don't have, you know, everybody's got a radiation of their body.
So, it'll help your body pull that out.
But again, it's a homeopath, it doesn't work quickly.
There's nothing else you can really do to keylate that out.
If you're using a die, then you can use some other keylaters like different binders, like the clear binder, or Pectisol C can be helpful.
That can be beneficial.
If there's anything with the rife, I'd say that I had throw away the foot bath, doing the clear-line detox would be helpful.
But you don't start that down afterwards.
Probably been doing some of those already, but doing the clear-line detox once a day can be helpful for them.